[Music]
as we've been doing this millionaire
research one of the pieces of data that
we've discovered is by studying 10,000
millionaires that the average
millionaire drives a 4-year old car with
41,000 miles on it and of course it's
paid for and they haven't had car
payments in decades which is how they
became a millionaire because the average
car payment now is over five hundred
dollars about five hundred four dollars
a month over eighty four months if you
invest five hundred and four dollars
from age 30 to age 70 you'll have
somewhere around five million dollars in
your Roth IRA I hope you like your car
our advice knowing that car is lose 60
to 70 percent of their value in the
first four years is to buy a quality
used car unless you have a net worth in
excess of a million dollars then if you
want to buy a new car you can afford to
take the loss on it but the worst car
accidents do happen on the showroom
floor well Dave I'm always worried about
buying a used car well what are you
driving if you're driving a car that you
bought two months ago it's now a used
car if you buy on driving a car you
bought five years ago it's a used car
what are you driving listen the vehicle
quality is so high now that you we get
through 300 thousand miles out of a car
most of these cars run and run and run
and run and run if you have take care of
them so don't buy a new car unless
you've got a net worth in excess of a
million dollars now how do you negotiate
the best deal on the car well the same
way you do a lot of things a couple of
keys to negotiating one is he with the
most knowledge wins so study learn about
that car go on trader.com
go on Kelley Blue Book and edmunds.com
and look up stuff about the car Google
the car read articles about the car look
at different versions of the car
different packages that are on the car
a luxury package the standard package
the two-door the four-door the different
engines that are in that particular car
to learn all about a Honda Civic if
you're going to buy a Honda Civic learn
people impulse a big purchase like a car
that makes you stupid
you don't impulse that you study that
and then pay cash of course now most the
time paying cash means that you are
doing a bank transfer but sometimes you
can walk in with the cash and just lay
it on the table it's not that much money
I mean $7,000 $10,000 $15,000 whatever
it kind of blows a dealer of dealers
mind but certainly if you're buying from
an individual when you put cash on the
table it says we have a deal it doesn't
say oh I need to check with my banker
you ever sold a car on Craigslist I need
to check with my banker and then you
never hear from him again I'll take it
but my banker I'm doing they're here
from again when you like cash on the
table there's no I need you taking that
banker in there it's a done deal baby
it's locked in right and listen doc just
don't get married to one car be prepared
to walk away listen when you bought
something emotionally even the most
inept seller recognizes the body
language changes I mean you guys know
when somebody's bought something right
even though they haven't done the deal
the negotiation is over once they know
you're married I marry this car so just
be quiet let them talk the seller that
is tell them you know you've looked this
car up you've studied a lot this seems a
little high and then be quiet let them
talk you can negotiate online there's a
lot of ways you can do it you can have
the car inspected and a good thing to do
too is check with one of our endorsed
local providers on the insurance side
and find out what it costs to insure
that car you might be looking at one
seven thousand dollar car that's almost
twice as much to insure as another seven
thousand dollar car you can get a quote
from one of them or on your existing
cars jump in there and get
from the LP most people that get a quote
from our LPS because they're brokers
they shop among a bunch of different
people and they get the best possible
deal they save like 700 bucks that's the
average so and one in three drivers 33%
of you buy your insurance and you don't
shop your insurance before you buy it
that's just dumb it's an expensive thing
just like not shopping the car before
you buy that stuff don't do that